ce point
first 7
vaincus
que ce soit
et bien utile lors des matchs entre
challengeurs durant les 18 mois
précédent son match contre boris spassky
fischer a battu et a en partie détruit
certains des meilleurs joueurs
soviétique fait au moins cher balayé ses
adversaires comme des mouches il a
aligné une série de vingt victoires
consécutives c'est unique dans les
annales des échecs de haut niveau bobby
fischer ne passionnait pas uniquement le
monde des échecs mais le monde entier il
y à des affrontements en irlande du nord
henry kissinger multiplie les
allers-retours au vietnam
et pourtant l'actualité est dominée par
les echets ce tome annexes nous
espérions tous qu'il devienne champion
du monde d'échecs chasse tient le seul
joueur qui lui restait à abattre
c'était boris spassky
les soviétiques dominer le monde des
échecs et je pensais que ce serait bon
pour l'amérique et pour la démocratie
qu'un américain remporte le titre
mondial
politiquement
l'enjeu ne pouvait pas être plus élevés
aux yeux de l'opinion publique
l'urss et les états unis étaient
considérés comme des ennemis qui me
n'est pas une guerre réelle mais qui
essaye en permanence de se surpasser
mutuellement
une famille où la force de l'urss venait
du fait que les soviétiques avaient fait
des échecs leur sport national
les aides spent il dépenser des sommes
astronomiques pour cela il avait des
centaines de grands maîtres
lebron est mu a remporté tous les
tournois tout les olympiades d'échecs
colline piette et acolyte château
d'abbadia les jeunes et les charmes pour
le régime communiste le titre de
champion du monde avait une importance
idéologique particulière l'état utilisé
le jeu d'échecs comme preuve de sa
supériorité intellectuelle
un rapport à l'occident considérés comme
des cas dans la couronne mondiale devait
rester en ligne en soliste à l'aîné
et l'hiver nos meilleurs alliés et nous
sommes en urss
les joueurs de talent bénéficier des
aides financières et d'entraînement
personnalisé les meilleurs joueurs
jouissait de toutes sortes de privilèges
aux états unis nous n'avions rien de
tout cela
nous devions nous débrouiller tout seul
et voici qu'arrive cet américain qui
s'en va tout seul affronter la machine
échiquéenne soviétique nation c'était
une affaire de prestige national
fischer a compris qu'il ne représentait
pas seulement lui-même mais tout le
monde libre je crois que la pression
était trop forte pour lui
je suis de suite en commun
j'ai rencontré bobby fischer dans un
club d'échecs de manhattan j'avais 14
ans il en avait 8
il était le plus jeune du club
c'était un garçon sympathique discret et
bien élevé et jean à sa mère travaillait
elle avait deux emplois l élever seule
ses deux enfants bobby jones dji regina
était le génie de la famille elle
parlait plusieurs langues dont le russe
elle travaillait en tant qu'opérateur
east et les graphistes infirmières et en
tant que sous 2 et elle était titulaire
d'un doctorat en hématologie et et
activiste communiste
le fbi y avait sur elle un dossier très
complet sa mère était surveillé par les
viiip la soupçonnaient d'être une
espionne soviétique
à cette époque les juifs et les
communistes étaient souvent mis dans le
même panier
c'est pour cela que sa mère agnés les
origines juives avaient donné des
instructions pour le cas du poser de
questions sur le perron de leur
appartement place rincon n'ai rien à
vous dire
c'était la réponse que sa mère lui
disait de faire
il faut rendre hommage
6 pensez à votre propre enfance et
imaginer que tous les soirs après
l'école nous tous les week-ends vous
avez consacré l'intégralité de votre
temps à l'étude des échecs à la pratique
et à la compétition
charles paris fischer dispose d'une
intelligence hors du commun
mais le génie ne se limite pas à une
aptitude qui vous est donné à la
naissance
le génie c'est aussi le désir de faire
quelque chose et la capacité à faire des
sacrifices
le génie c'est l'aptitude à se consacrer
de manière obsessionnelle à ce qu'on a
envie de faire
et pendant ce temps les nac des études
ont été menées sur des grands
compositeurs des grands chirurgiens tu
es grand joueur d'échecs pour tenter de
voir s'il existe un dénominateur commun
à tous ces virtuoses et bien ce sont
presque tous des gens qui ont commencé
par investir dix mille heures de
pratique dans leur spécialité
impérial dès son plus jeune âge bobby
fischer n'a vécu que pour les échecs
même quand ils mangeaient il avait son
échiquier avec lui et il étudiait de
nouvelles variantes la passion joue un
rôle essentiel dans l'accomplissement du
génie avec la contrainte
vous ne tiendriez jamais un tel niveau
d'obsession il n'y avait rien qu'ils
n'aient mais davantage que jouer aux
échecs
jean origin a été tellement inquiète
qu'elle a emmené bobby voir un
psychiatre
mais celui ci lui a dit soyez sans
crainte où il ya plus grave que d'être
obsédé par les échecs
quand les gens lui demandait comment il
avait fait il répondait un jour je suis
devenu fort tout simplement à un moment
donné il était au dessus de tous les
autres
quand fish et rouvre est un magazine
d'échec ça se passait comme ça ok ça
très bien on avait l'impression qu'ils
se contentaient de regarder les images
mais pas du tout il rejouait mentalement
en quelques secondes toutes les parties
qu'il voyait est la fille aux sacs ou
après coup
au départ nous étions de force égale
puis il est devenu champion des états
unis qu il avait fait un bond en avant
prodige grippe
il est devenu célèbre en 1958
à l'époque les joueurs d'échecs ne
gagnait pas beaucoup d'argent
mon père a organisé une tournée à
travers les états unis
il jouait en simultanée contre 40 à 80
joueurs et ils touchaient quelque chose
comme 5 dollars par échiquier
reggina voulait que son fils devienne
célèbre un jour elle m'a appelé pour me
dire je voudrais que bobby sue est
invitée dimanche sur la deuxième chaîne
si je lui demande il refusera donc
j'aimerais que ce soit toi qui t'en
occupes baup il voulait simplement
progresser aux échecs elle boulet de la
publicité
la célébrité est une médaille à deux
faces tout le monde a rêvé un jour
d'être célèbre au début c'est amusant
mais quand vous voulez avoir la paix en
privé comme en public
le côté plaisant disparaît très vite de
plus pour le psychisme d'un adolescent
la célébrité peut avoir des conséquences
terribles
elle bouleverse tout son univers il y
avait plein de gens autour de lui qui
voulait profiter de sa notoriété
il avait toutes sortes de motivation et
ce n'était pas toujours dans son intérêt
il y avait des gens qui voulaient se
faire de l'argent grâce à lui devenir
ses associés mais dans son dos il disait
du mal de lui crû il ne supportait pas
ça et surtout il ne supportait pas la
presse il était tellement hors du commun
qu'il en devenait une cible facile pour
la caricature
non monsieur fisher avait un regard bien
à lui sur le monde
il n'a pas été socialisés de la même
façon que la plupart des gens chacune de
ces idées émanait de ses propres
réflexions dans sa jeunesse c'était déjà
quelqu'un de très particulier et ça n'a
fait qu'empirer
je suis entraîneur de niveau
international et olympique
je suis également champion du monde de
développé couché j'ai entraîné de
nombreuses célébrités
mais personne ne soutient la comparaison
avec bobby fischer il s'intéressait
énormément au corps humain à son
fonctionnement et aux moyens de
l'optimiser il m'a dit j'aimerais
travailler la force de ma main je veux
que l'aiguillé de ce dynamomètre arrive
au maximum je lui ai répondu que l'homme
le plus fort du monde n'arrivait pas à
une pression de 100 kg et il m'a dit moi
j'arriverais à 105 kg et quand je lui ai
demandé pourquoi il m'a dit quand je
serrerai la main de ce petit russe je
veux qu'il le s'en passer
faire de la natation du racket ball un
sport on se débrouillait plutôt bien on
faisait aussi un peu de bodybuilding un
jour je lui dis répète après moi je suis
un vainqueur un champion je ne suis pas
un perdant et là il m'a dit c'est quoi
cette histoire de perdants tu sais bien
que je suis un champion
bobby est la personnalité la plus
intéressante que j'ai photographié
voici une photo de bobby il disait que
s'exercer à l'apnée était un excellent
entraînement préparer son match contre
ce parce qu' il m'a interrogé sur les
reportages que j'avais fait je lui ai
dit que je venais de finir une série sur
un joueur des new york jets
il a trouvé ça génial et il a voulu tout
savoir sur ses méthodes d'entraînement
ils voulaient s'entraîner exactement
comme la
il m'a laissé prendre toutes les photos
que je voulais mais ça aurait pu
également très mal se passer
il était souvent méprisant avec les
autres l'organisation du match a été
attribué à l'islande tout simplement
parce que c'est le pays qui avait fait
l'offre la plus élevée mais bobby ne
voulait pas aller là-bas ils disaient
que le pays était trop petit qu'il
manquait d'infrastructures et de moyens
de communication
en glissement il avait une armée
d'avocats qui ne cessait de formuler des
exigences
mais dans le même temps nous ne savions
pas si fischer accepterait de venir en
islande
l'obstacle principal a été le montant
des prix je leur ai dit que la question
de l'argent avaient déjà été réglées et
que nous ne reviendrions plus là dessus
réservé aux prospects street est le
risque que le match n'ait pas lieu
c'était bien réel on a soi-même ou wifi
fischer avait déjà claqué la porte de
plusieurs tournois et son attitude
n'était pas forcément du bluff changer
sans cesse d'avis et puis un jour il m'a
posé les mains sur les épaules et il m'a
dit harry je vais aller en islande et le
lendemain je lis dans les journaux qu'il
n'ira pas en islande
il ordonne
la situation était hallucinante il
fallait conclure le contrat mais bobby
refusé de le signer et tout à coup il a
disparu
ses mobiles étaient à pasadena en
californie
ma mission consistait à le convaincre de
se rendre en islande et de jouer le
match pour l'attribution du titre
mondial
rien ne se passe et il n'avait toujours
pas son billet alors je lui ai dit il
faut que j'aille à new york
mon père est malade viens avec moi ça te
rapprochera de l'islande qui m'a dit
c'est une bonne idée du voyage et des
cannes a mis d'accord une certaine
manière je le rapprocher de l'endroit où
ils devaient aller nous l'avons emmené à
kennedy airport jusqu'au fichiers d'aïs
cela indique airlines malheureusement un
photographe de presse l'espionnaient
quand bobby la vue il est parti en
courant
il a piqué un véritable sprint je me
suis retourné pour l'arrêter j'ai levé
les mains sans dire un mot
bobby a continué à courir il est sorti
du hall
il a sauté dans notre limousine et a
quitté l'aéroport pour aller où
personne ne le savait
novellino et tout ça seulement à trois
jours avant le début du match
l'histoire des échecs était sur le fil
du rasoir
j'ai dit à bobby si tu veux tu peux tu
installée à new blood stone dans la
maison de mes parents alors island
david bowers
ouest
couiza
bobby était dans la maison de ses dit le
père de ces dix étaient en train de
mourir d'un cancer ils ont tout essayé
pour le convaincre d'aller en islande un
moment seydi a même dit à bobby tu sais
mon père est en train de mourir et bobby
a répondu c'est pas grave ça ne dérange
pas il n'y avait pas moyen de le déloger
de cette maison a été la semaine la plus
stressante de ma vie
lors de son séjour chez nous il a dit à
un moment c'est fini je n'irai pas
on apprend entre autres mr fillon
nous ne contrôlions plus la situation at
il fallait amener fischer en islande
l'union soviétique avait l'impression
qu'on se moquait du champion du monde en
titre était sur le point de faire
revenir spassky en urss
boris m'a dit 'ça tôt mais la situation
est sérieuse
il faut régler ça au plus haut niveau je
crois que goodman dur thorarinsson a
demandé au premier ministre islandaise
d'appeler henrique synge r si je ne
voulais pas y aller alors je les
appelais je lui ai dit allez-y les états
unis d'amérique voulait que bobby aille
en islande et qu'il remporte le titre
mondial
entre temps le multi millionnaire
britannique james layton avait doublé
les montants des prix la réponse de
fisher à kissinger a été oui j'ai décidé
de jouer
un studio mais nous voulions lui faire
un accueil ligne darrois qui ont pu mais
lorsqu'il a vu la foule qui l'attendait
il a dévalée la passerelle à toute
vitesse et s'est engouffré dans la
première voiture du convoi
j'ai été son garde du corps personnel en
islande
ça a été un grand moment pour moi
j'étais davantage un ami qu'un garde du
corps n'avaient pas un caractère facile
il pouvait être très aimable mais ils
pouvaient également explosé comme un
volcan
il valait mieux savoir qu'en parler donc
bobby était enfin en islande les jours
et il le championnat du monde le
gouvernement islandais
le président islandais les ambassadeurs
de l'union soviétique est des états unis
et de nombreux invités étrangers ont
fuit la salle était comble fou ce match
a passionné les foules
c'était comme une super bowl pour suivre
les parties les gens n'allaient pas
travailler les gens formaient des
attroupements devant les écrans télé
dans les vitrines
il y avait des groupies à saül square le
match était retransmis en direct et
tellement c'était important
pour le suspense boris spassky champion
du monde en titre et hélas avec tous ces
secondes en mai fischer n'étaient pas là
était introuvable
nous étions désespérés et ses droits
là où personne ne pouvait dire avec
certitude si fischer allait finir par
arriver même si en l'occurrence c'était
le match de saint lô a beaucoup de gens
pensaient que toutes ces tergiversations
avaient pour but d'énerver de troubles
espace qui ça d'ailleurs été le cas mais
je ne crois pas que c'était le but
recherché par fischer rien de tout cela
n'était dirigé contre spassky fisher
était aux prises avec ses propres démons
des brichères disait toujours je ne
parle jamais de mon père c'est ce qui
m'a permis de comprendre qu'il devait y
avoir quelque chose de particulier
concernant son père que personne ne le
savait le fbi avait un dossier de 900
pages sur regina fisher et ce dossier
établi c'est que contrairement à ce que
la famille déclarait le père de bobby
n'était pas gerhard fischer mais un
dénommé paul n'aimait ni et gerhard
fischer figure sur l'acte de naissance
de bobby mais il n'est jamais venu aux
états unis regina et paul n'aimait ni se
sont rencontrés à l'université près de
denver
elles ont une liaison plus tard regina
et elle et vivre ailleurs et à l'emmener
bobby avec l origine à n'avait pas
d'argent elle sollicitait régulièrement
les services l'aide sociale aulnay mais
ni de son côté consultait souvent des
travailleurs sociaux
il se faisait du souci au sujet de bobby
il disait que tout petit bobby était un
enfant assez instable ils craignent
qu'il ne soit pas élevé convenablement
plus tard quand bobby est allé vivre à
new york paul lui rendais visite ils se
comportaient vis-à-vis de bobby comme un
père par exemple quand il l'emmenait au
restaurant il de réprimander s'il ne
mangeait pas proprement un jour bobby a
demandé à sa mère ou épaules pour eux ne
viennent-ils plus me voir à la mort de
nomeny reggina a dit à bobby qu'il était
son vrai père lobby n'avait que neuf ans
quand il labrador chasse les échecs ont
été en refuge pour bobby et sont devenus
sa seule obsession
et
nous avions l'impression que ce match
n'aurait jamais lieu
mais finalement il a eu lieu et il a été
phénoménal comment épeler vous le mot
soulagement
je me souviens qu'à un moment j'ai dit à
l'antenne nous avons de la chance de
pouvoir être les témoins de ce match
entre bobby fischer et boris spassky
non bobby seay bobby m'a dit ça me
dérange
je ne supporte pas ces caméras
la première partie a donné lieu à
quelques passes d'armes psychologique
dans l'ouverture
mais très vite le jeu s'est calmé et au
bout de 28 coups la position semblait
parfaitement égale tout indiqué que les
joueurs allaient s'entendre pour faire
nul et passer à la partie suivante il en
était à la finale toutes les pièces
avaient été échangés à part un fou de
chaque côté et quelques pions c'était
l'égalité parfaite
la position était complètement
symétrique fischer a perdu les pédales
il a commis une erreur d'amateur il a
pris un pion mais en échange son fou
s'est retrouvée prise au piège y mais
c'était une erreur monumentale l'île
d'un débutant en prenant ce pion il a
permis à spassky de capturer sont fous
on n'arrivait pas à y croire
les slops raclée ça ressemble à une
erreur mais quand fischer joue un tel
coup on se dit qu'il ya peut-être une
explication ou une combinaison qui nous
a échappé au pire
fischer tenait là nul
et il a voulu prouver à ce parce qu'il
était prêt à en découdre et en faisant
ça il a commis une gaffe ça a été un
vrai coup de trafalgar et où c'était
inexplicable je ne sais toujours pas
comment ça a pu se produire
ce prêt ce qui avait remporté la
première partie
sur les 24 points en jeu fischer devait
embarquer 12 et demi pour être champion
une victoire donne un point une défaite
zéro point et une nulle à demi point les
négociations d'avant match à stipulait
que les caméras devait être silencieuse
bobby a dit elles ne sont pas silencieux
et ça me dérange et clem plainte
il se plaignait que le bruit des caméras
l'empêcher de réfléchir et de se
concentrer
d'ailleurs je crois que c'était sincère
à mon avis fischer souffrait
d'hyperacousie une maladie caractérisée
par une hypersensibilité au bruit
et il a exigé que les caméras soient
retirés
fillon il m'a demandé de retirer les
caméras de la salle
à l'origine
you have to start
même quand un joueur n'est pas présent
au début d'une part le rôle de l'arbitré
et de démarrer sa pendule
faisons savions que fisher était capable
d'abandonner un match pour une simple
broutille
nous avions donc très peur qu'il s'en
aille et que le match s'arrête là pompey
dit notre champ à bobby ne s'est pas
présenté mon rôle d arbitre consistait à
le déclarer perdant par forfait je me
suis évidemment demander si cette
décision était loyal ou correct mais je
n'avais pas le choix
les sonnailles cette nuit là je me suis
réveillé en larmes à cause de mon rôle
d'arbitré j'avais été amenés à détruire
un génie et jean s
il était mené 2 à 0
c'est difficile de remonter un tel
retard dans un match de 24 parties la
moitié de la planète et est convaincu
que le match était venu et qu'il ne
reviendrait pas pourquoi d'ailleurs
serait survenu dans une situation aussi
difficile
la nuit il est venu frapper à ma porte
vers une ou deux heures du matin nous
sommes sortis marché
nous nous sommes assis et avons observé
des animaux
et il aimait les animaux
nous avons beaucoup parlé mais n'avait
pas parlé de son enfance
c'était un sujet à éviter tiens m'a
raconté qu'à partir de l'âge de 2 ou 3
ans sa mère le laissait régulièrement
seul avec sa soeur toute la journée
il a parlé de sa solitude jean à regina
était une femme brillante mais ce
n'était pas une mère comme les autres
elle a imposé à ses enfants de nombreux
déménagements tous les deux ou trois
mois alors qu'ils étaient encore très
petit dès sa plus tendre enfance
bobby a eu des relations très
conflictuelles avec sa mère il n'aimait
pas que sa mère soit avec lui à tel
point qu'il voulait que ce soit sa soeur
jane qui l'accompagnent lors de ces
tournois à l'étranger
il refusait de jouer en présence de sa
mère originaire a quitté leur
appartement de brooklyn
alors que bobby n'avait que 16 ans bobby
a demandé à sa mère de partir je ne sais
même pas si le lui a dit poliment et
allait partir au fond il a rejeté parce
qu'elles étaient comme lui déterminé
égocentrique et polariser sur ses
objectifs
peut-être qu'en l'occurrence il s'est
détaché d'une partie de lui même
my man 1960 reggina est parti en europe
pour passer son doctorat en médecine
bobby a continué à vivre dans
l'appartement de la place lincoln à
brooklyn je lui ai rendu visite dans son
appartement de brooklyn
il était infesté de cafards il y avait
des livres des chèques un peu partout et
lui même avait l'air complètement
désorienté le fait est que sa mère l'a
abandonné imaginez un peu votre père est
mort et votre mère s'en va tout
simplement
q ressentez-vous
que se passe-t-il dans votre esprit
par d'éventuels el watan
et oui et non et c'est cette barre à
fisher était d'accord pu continuer mais
il voulait que la troisième partie ait
lieu dans une pièce fermée et 100
spectateurs
il y avait une salle de ping-pong
d'arrière espace qui a donné son accord
gré une fois que le match a commencé un
changement de lieu n'est possible
qu'avec l'accord des deux joueurs se
passe qui aurait pu remporter le match
par forfait
rien ne l'obligé à jouer dans une
arrière salle s'il avait refusé
fischer n'aurait pas joué et le match
n'aurait pas continué propice tantôt des
game to bobby a recommencé à faire des
histoires je ne veux pas si je ne veux
pas ça et c est à un moment il a dit
c'est inacceptable je me retire on
arrête le match match face au yen ce
match et tous les deux joueurs était
double devant la table de jeu et je les
ai attrapé par le col tous les deux je
les ai forcé à s'asseoir et je leur ai
dit maintenant il faut jouer
paulus et boris a joué son premier coup
presque automatiquement
kyle côté ob mois la partie était
retransmise par le biais d'une caméra de
surveillance européen
dans la salle les spectateurs pouvaient
suivre l évolution de la partie coup
après coup
une telle furie dans la troisième partie
bobby a opté pour une défense qu'il
n'avait jamais joué la défense benoni
son vélo ni signifie fils de ma douleur
une défense très risqué tlj
quand vous jouez cette défense c'est
comme si vous disiez à votre adversaire
ne feront pas nul
ce sera un combat à mort il a joué son
cavalier sur le bord de l'échiquier aux
échecs il ya un proverbe qui dit heinz
bring rame rame bring comment on chante
cavaliers au bord cavaliers morts c'est
contraire à l'esprit du jeu ce n'est pas
considéré comme un bon coup en principe
le champ de bataille c'est le centre de
l'échiquier
c'est au centre qu'on installe ses
pièces ou du moins on s'arrange pour
qu'elle contrôle le centre en installant
son cavalier sur le bord fischer a pris
le risque de le voir échanger contre un
fou c'est ce qui s'est passé et ça lui a
fait deux pions doublé très laid sur ce
côté de l'échiquier
c'est très inesthétique
est ce parce qu'apparemment ce parce
qu'ils n'avaient pas beaucoup étudié ce
genre de position car c'est un coût qui
est très peu joué et cela me spassky
dans une situation psychologique assez
difficile à ce qui n'a pas trouvé la
bonne suite de coups il a subi le jeu
fischer a remporté sa première partie
contre ce parce qu'il ait marqué son
premier point au tableau d'affichage
et vous ça dans les bars les gens
faisaient des paris sur le prochain coup
tout comme ils parient sur le prochain
point au baseball
le jeu d'échecs a littéralement explosé
photo
les deux joueurs étaient à égalité deux
ennemis partout
ce parce qu'ils osent pas ce qui n'était
pas lui même michel a beaucoup souffert
de tous ces esclaves
il n'a pas joué à son vrai niveau et
rigueur
ça a été un fiasco la préparation de ce
pass qui n'a servi à rien quand deux
personnes sont face à face la sauce ou
méthode la psychologie des relations
interpersonnelles a horreur du vide il
était aussi tu baises pavillon ton
opposant va occuper la position
dominante
nous avions reçu plusieurs lettres de
mise en garde
elles nous disaient de faire attention
car fisher était capable les soviétiques
pensais qu'il y avait des câbles dans
les chaises et que l'éclairage avait été
trafiqué pour déstabiliser boris dans sa
concentration et boris a fini par
craquer parce que ce parce qu'il s'est
plaint de radiation qu'il aurait
ressenti durant la rencontre
selon lui il y avait peut-être quelque
chose dans la chaise ou dans le coussin
de la chaise et il y avait peut-être
quelque chose dans l'éclairage
quinze maisons examiner des chaises et
l'éclairage pour voir s'il n'y avait pas
un coup fourré de la part des américains
les fans tout ce qu'ils ont trouvé ça a
été deux mouches mortels
kane sexe la partie numéro 6 est la plus
connue est sans doute la partie la plus
reproduits de tout le match et with why
que c'est une symphonie de beauté
paisible
le premier qui bobby fischer a surpris
tout le monde et ouvrait presque
toujours c'est parti avec champions roi
en jouant eux quatre fisher était connu
pour être extrêmement constants quand il
avait décidé qu'ils mangeraient des
flocons d'avoine et un oeuf dur au petit
déjeuner il mangeait ça pendant des
années avec les échecs c'était la même
chose il jouait les mêmes ouverture
match après match et on cette partie à
la surprise générale il a opté pour
l'ouverture anglaise en jouant c4 la
préparation de ce pass qui ne servait
plus à rien je suis sûr qu'il
s'attendait à beaucoup de choses ne pas
à sa fille cher n'a pas joué son jeu
habituel
il a changé de style en développant un
jeu tranquille très positionnelle
étouffé peu à peu les pièces de ce pass
qui se connaît
le webcast c'était une belle partie
alors je ne sais pas quoi dire de plus
c'était un modèle de précision
c'était tellement beau qu'à la fin de la
rencontre
quand les spectateurs ont applaudi
spasmes à ce qui s'est levé et il a
applaudi fischer
un livre en rentrant à l'hôtel fischer a
dit tu as vu ce qu'a fait ce parce qu'il
est très fair play
c'est un vrai sportif
kind twenty one which may la 21e partie
a été ajournée au 40e coup pour
permettre deux joueurs d' analyser la
position star du net
j'avais rendez vous dans la matinée avec
spassky pour une série de photos
il est arrivé droit sur moi il m'a dit
il y à un nouveau champion du monde
il s'appelle robert james fischer je
suis allé voir bobby dans sa chambre
d'hôtel et jules lui ai dit ce pas ce
qui vient d'abandonner et je voulais
être le premier à te féliciter
bobby et voulait partir
les gens frapper à sa porte lui ne
voulait qu'une chose se réfugier dans
les montagnes sans quelqu'un nous a
apporté le new york post la une dizaine
bobby est champion du monde
m
le jour où sa mère s'était rendu compte
qu'elle ne pourrait pas l'empêcher de
jouer aux échecs
elle lui avait dit très bien joué aux
échecs quand ça se sera passé
tu pourras peut-être faire quelque chose
d'important de ta vie
j'avais le pressentiment qu'il allait
lui arriver quelque chose de terrible
savais pas ce que c'était mais ça me
faisait on le fait chez eux après le
match
fisher était probablement l'homme le
plus célèbre de l'inscription de
jésus-christ or il tenait énormément à
sa vie privée
ça lui a posé un gros problème et
reproche
et non plus après sa victoire il n'avait
aucune idée de ce qu'il voulait faire de
sa vie à 29 ans il avait atteint son
objectif principal est où il avait 29
ans et il n'avait jamais eu d'enfant ce
les deux hommes de chasse master's 11e
place je crois qu'au départ il avait
envie de jouer contre ce jeune russe
karpov et je pense qu'il l'aurait
emporté facilement mais quelque chose en
lui lui disait qu'il pourrait aussi
perdre et ça aurait été la mort pour lui
il n'a pas voulu prendre ce risque
alors pour éviter ça il a multiplié les
demandes de modification du règlement
pour la fédération soviétique d'échec il
était politiquement impossible
d'accepter toutes les exigences de
fischer
la fédération internationale des échecs
a satisfait 80 15% de ses exigences
mais ça n'a pas suffi il n'a pas défendu
sans titre
nous nous étions tous très déçus ils
l'avaient trahi le monde des échecs et
les maîtres américains
oui nous avons vécu ça comme une
trahison
je suis allé en californie pour des
photos en cours de route
je suis allé chercher bobby à pasadena
il passait son temps dans une sorte de
lieu de culte mieux quand il m'a parlé
de désarmement nucléaire d'arsenal
militaire de missiles intercontinentaux
tout ça pendant une heure et demie il
était membre de l'église universelle de
dieu depuis 1962 après son titre de
champion du monde c'est église lui a
offert un lieu de résidence
les membres de l'église universelle de
dieu croyait dans les principes
fondamentaux de la bible
certaines personnes nous ont comparé à
des intégristes en gros le retour du
christ est imminent et nous devons nous
préparer à surtout je lui ai dit que
c'était une bande d'illuminés
mais c'était la voix qu'il avait décidé
de suivre
ah ouais je suis allé le voir dans son
appartement à pasadena mais c'était sans
savoir très déprimé nous avions de
longues discussions sur la bible du
genre pourquoi ce moment ici que
faisons-nous ici qu'est ce que la vie
c'est là qu'il a commencé à perdre la
tête et il avait l'impression d'être
manipulés par les russes il avait aussi
très peur du mossad les services secrets
israéliens
ils croyaient qu'on pouvait l'espionné
par le biais de la radioactivité et par
d'autres moyens
c'est plombages dentaires il croyait que
les russes pouvaient envoyer des signaux
danser plombage par le téléphone qui ont
dit ah le papier aluminium par les
fenêtres médial radioactivité s'étaient
de la paranoïa avec les membres de
l'église nous avons essayé de le ramener
vers une vie normale s'est détourné de
l'église universelle de dieu parce que
l'une de leurs prophéties ne s'était pas
réalisée fischer s'était senti trahi il
a écrit un pamphlet contre l'église et
son fondateur armstrong en disant que
personne n'avait le droit de contrôler
l'esprit d'autrui
la renier dieu et à partir de là son
état s'est aggravé
il s'est mis à délirer complètement
il lisait les protocoles des sages de
sion
quand il m'en a parlé je les mets en
garde je lui ai dit ce livre est une
mystification c'est de la propagande
antisémite qui a notamment été utilisé
par hitler il a commencé à s'intéresser
aux idées conspirationnistes il ya tout
un tas de gens qui rêvait de dominer le
monde
à partir de là nous avons beaucoup moins
fréquentes et bobby ne voulions pas que
nos enfants aient contact avec ses tanks
le certes très célèbre mais qui était
devenu un antisémite virulent parfois à
table ils se mettaient à dire n'importe
quoi des juifs ont fait ceci les juifs
ont fait cela et nous ne pouvions pas
accepter ça sous notre toit
sa mère était juive son vrai père était
juif
c'était de la folie furieuse comment un
jeune homme juif ou va-t-il devenir
antisémite c'est de la paranoïa il
croyait en l'existence d'une
conspiration contre lui c'était comme
s'ils étaient en guerre contre lui même
elle s'est renfermé sur lui même ses
proches ont rappelé à ces années
sauvages
notre dernière conversation l'a mis hors
de lui
je lui ai dit si tu le joues plus aux
échecs bientôt plus personne ne te
demandera deux jours et on a trouvé ça
inacceptable de ma part et ça a été la
fin de notre amitié
et puis une loque dans l'histoire des
échecs on trouve un nombre
disproportionné de joueurs extrêmement
talentueux qui parallèlement souffrait
de graves problèmes psychologiques
les joueurs d'échecs évolue dans un
univers a fini et abstrait qui les
oblige en fin de compte à reformater
leurs esprits sont le premier conte
chaque joueur a théoriquement le choix
entre 20 coups possibles et si vous
multipliez 20 parvint cela signifie
qu'il existe 400 positions possibles
après le premier coup c'est comme un
arbre avec de plus en plus de
ratification vous jouez un premier coup
puis un autre et à chaque fois il ya
plusieurs possibilités
tout à coup ça devient une jungle le
nombre de positions théoriquement
possible lors d'une partie d'échecs et
quelque chose comme 10 suivi de 45,0
c'est comme le nombre d'atomes dans le
système solaire
il faut anticiper les coups de
l'adversaire et comme on ne sait pas ce
qu'il va jouer on étudie chacune de ses
possibilités
un bon joueur d'échecs doit être
paranoïaque sur l'échiquier
mais si vous transposez cette paranoïa
dans votre vie quotidienne et un aller
au devant de gros ennuis vous finirez
par considérer le monde réel à travers
le prisme du jeu d'échecs
certains joueurs ont très mal fini alors
on a tous envie de croire que les échecs
n'y était pour rien mais malgré tout
c'est peut-être le cas
on est devenu un être instable
deviendrait un monomaniaque du jeu
d'échecs courent de grands risques de
basculer dans un happy oui il ya
plusieurs exemples de joueurs dotés de
facultés exceptionnelles qui ont
développé ce genre de maladie mentale
ville ton corps tu n'as affirmé avoir
joué une partie avec un mort il a même
indiqué les coûts qui avait été joué
rubinstein a sauté par une fenêtre parce
qu'une mouche pour chasser wildenstein
et à séjourner en asile psychiatrique
the time it's à la fin de sa vie
s'imaginer qu'ils jouent et aux échecs
avec dieu par ondes interposées et il
battait dieu
carlos torres est entièrement
déshabillée dans un bus le joueur qui a
le plus influencé l'évolution du jeu
d'échecs au 19e siècle est un américain
du nom de paul murphy a malheureusement
il présente des traits communs avec
fisher paul murphy était un joueur
américain qui a épaté le monde entier
avec sa façon de jouer
mais dès l'âge de 26 ans il arrivait
qu'on le retrouve errant dans les rues
l'air hagard en train de se parler à lui
même il souffrait de schizophrénie
paranoïde qu'ils sa tournée en europe en
1858 et 1859 a été un grand moment de
l'histoire des échecs mais la suite de
cette tournée il a arrêté de jouer il ya
de nombreuses similitudes entre morphy
et fisher les gens les compare souvent
l'un à l'autre ils ont tous les deux
arrêtés de jouer au summum de leur
domination ils ont basculé tous deux
dans la névrose et la psychose
en 1990 il réapparaît à pasadena il
avait pris quelques kilos
il me montre une lettre cher monsieur
fisher vous êtes un génie
vous êtes le mozart des échecs le plus
grand joueur qui je n'ai vécu et je
voudrais que vous repreniez le jeu
d'échecs et par une certaine ita on m'a
dit harry je veux savoir à quoi elle
ressemble tout à coup il était d'humeur
très romantique
cet état a réfuté tous les arguments
qu'ils avançaient pour justifier le fait
qu'il ne voulait plus jouer et l'a
organisé un tournoi le monde des échecs
attendaient son retour depuis 20 ans
chaque année il y avait eu des rumeurs
il est en train de négocier on essaie de
le convaincre mais il ne jouez jamais et
voilà qu'ils s'apprêtent à rejouer
il devait affronter spassky en
yougoslavie le match il est annoncé avec
grand fracas comme la revanche du match
pour le championnat du monde
je pense parce que nous vivons de match
tout le match la vie durant la guerre on
participants à cette rencontre
fischer violer l'embargo des nations
unies le gouvernement américain lui a
adressé une lettre ne jouait pas cette
rencontre vous risquez la prison
d'un point de vue échiquéen le match de
1992 n'avait aucune valeur
ils ont très bien joué mais leur niveau
de jeu était celui de 1972 c'était comme
de vieux boxeur qui remonte sur le ring
pour se faire payer une dernière fois
c'était un spectacle assez triste il
était évident que fisher connaissent pas
ce qui n'était plus à leur meilleur
niveau il n'était que l'ombre du joueur
qu'ils avaient été émis cher à remporter
le match et il a ramassé quelques
millions de dollars mais des poursuites
ont été engagées contre lui qu'il a payé
un prix très élevé il a perdu son pays
ne pouvait plus rentrer aux états unis
s'est retrouvé inculpé on s'est
interrogé sur le bien fondé de cette
inculpation mais fisher avait enfreint
la loi
et comme il ne pouvait pas revenir aux
états unis où il aurait bien arrêtés et
ils se retrouvaient expatriés je les
rencontre et en yougoslavie mais ça n'a
servi à rien
la sphère était déjà très mal engagé
news in j'ai rencontré site a gelé connu
personnellement c'était une fille très
gentille mais personne ne savait ce
qu'il faisait avec elle
john john italien hongrie en 1995 pour
lui rendre visite à budapest elle a été
la dernière de notre famille à l'avoir
vu la reggina est décédé en 1996 jean
danet et john ma femme est morte en 1998
d'une hémorragie cérébrale mais sans le
moindre signe avant coureur
point n'est alors dan
elle est morte en une demi-journée f des
c'était une tragédie
sa mère meurt sa soeur moby ne pouvait
plus espérer le moindre soutien familial
de plus il était toujours expatriés
son état ne cessé d'empirer il faut en
penser qu'il était au dessus de la
politique qu'il pouvait dire ce qu'il
voulait george bush lui a fait
comprendre qu'il avait les moyens de
l'attraper où qu'ils soient
franca pas j'ai reçu un appel en pcv
depuis le jeu près j'ai demandait qui
était à l'appareil il m'a dit c'est
bobby fischer je n'avais plus eu de ses
nouvelles depuis 22 ans mais apparemment
il avait gardé mon numéro et il s'en est
souvenu un moment où il a eu besoin de
moi
ouais je suis allé au japon pour essayer
de le sortir de prison
je l' ai revu le jour de son
anniversaire et il m'a demandé si je
pouvais le sortir de là et j'ai répondu
d'accord je vais voir ce que je peux
faire
et demain c'est le renard et ses soeurs
de discovery à l'iss 30 as tout à fait
c'est assez restreinte trace tout à
apporter notre petite nation de 300000
habitants a tenu tête aux états unis et
au japon
les deux plus grandes puissances
économiques au monde et à rapatrier
fisher sur son territoire gantois
restreinte
bayonne a dénoncé les stones sur paint
ball watch à nice
am j'ai rencontré bobby après son
arrivée en islande et maunel ville très
solitaire
qui en islande comme partout ailleurs
son comportement finissez par là c'est
tout le monde nous promener près du lac
au centre de reykjavik bavardions nous
allions prendre un café m'arrivait aussi
de le croiser dans les restaurants
koutchma il n'arrêtait pas de répéter
que les juifs étaient mauvais que les
états unis étaient mauvais ou que le
nucléaire était mauvais c'était une idée
fixe les nouvelles économies il n'y
avait pas moyen de le faire parler
d'autre chose
il en parlait de manière obsessionnelle
et compulsive la dernière fois que je
les croisais je lui ai demandé de ne pas
s'asseoir ma table car j'en avais par
dessus la tête
la pensée de la plupart des gens
évoluent à l'intérieur de limites très
étroites
certains réussissent à voir au delà de
ses limites
là ce sont les esprits créatifs ceux qui
découvrent quelque chose mais parfois
ils ne parviennent pas à revenir à leur
réalité tout son génie et sa maladie
sont intimement liés
je ne pense pas que bobby y aurait été
tellement hors du commun en termes de
créativité
s'il n'avait pas également été hors du
commun sur un autre plan celui que nous
appelons sa maladie
my soul to be jean guy hachey ce samedi
me grey mort à cause de ces troubles
psychiatriques
il souffrait d'une hypertrophie de la
prostate et il a refusé de se faire
soigner
il a refusé la dialyse s'il avait
accepté ça aurait pu prolonger sa vie je
lui avais donné une photo de reginald
john il l'avait avec lui à l'hôpital
lorsqu'il est mort apparemment les
derniers mots de fisher ont été rien ne
soigne mieux que le contact humain
enfin
cast son monument ce sont les parties
qu'il a jouées c'est parti
imaginez que vous aimiez un art par
exemple la peinture et imaginer que
picasso soit mort après avoir peint que
pendant cinq ans tout le reste de son
oeuvre n'aurait jamais vu le jour sur le
monde des échecs cela a été une tragédie
il a tout fait tout ça
il a percé les secrets du jeu d'échecs
dans son appartement miteux de brooklyn
il a été le meilleur joueur qui n'est
jamais existé
allez
barry meyer
oui new yok scellé
soit elles auront ces gars est glacial
et devait repenser pas
avec les chaises longues
m
bah
avec bar et oued et non
k
norway as
j'ai dit m
des batteries aux barbares et week-end